uh in the meantime we are following the
the situation with the president it's
covered of course a lot of people are
saying if the president united states
can get this uh then then who else is
next pretty much it's easier these days
to find someone who has not had covered
than someone who has dr anthony fauci
joins us right now the white house peak
medical advisor doctor very good seeing
you
um
the president's situation what you're
learning of it a lot of what we're
getting doctor is coming from uh
secondhand from
the president's physician and relayed to
his top medical authorities uh that was
not the case when president trump was
diagnosed uh is there a difference
should we be hearing more from his
personal physician
well we're hearing um
i think
more than one daily uh uh pronouncement
about what exactly is going on
so it's a written statement and then a
statement that's given through
a dr jaw and then i speak to
dr kevin o'connor
twice a day i spoke to him as recently
as last night at ten o'clock
and we went over the case carefully
and as he has been saying the president
is doing really quite well he continues
to improve
and i think that's another example of
what we've all been saying
of what it means of when you have the
interventions like vaccination doubly
boosted and being on an antiviral drug
that has a proven track record
of being very effective in preventing
the progression to severe disease
leading to hospitalization
the president
yeah yes i'm talking about paxo bid neil
he's on pax livid this is the second day
now on pax a bid he's tolerating it well
and he continues to improve i mean he
was better today than he was last night
and better yesterday than he was when he
first got the symptomatology um when you
did talk to the
president's physician um obviously you
both have to consider that the age of
the president um and and whether
you know
his getting back to a routine or at
least one from a distance is wise
what do you think
well
he is feeling well enough
that he is
fulfilling the duties from a virtual
standpoint neil you and i spoke about
when i got infected you know i'm a
little bit older than the president i
had symptomatology very similar to what
the president had i was on pax levid so
there's a lot of similarities there and
i did exactly the same as the president
was doing and it was
i wasn't any worse for the where
i did my work virtually the way the
president is doing so he's following the
course of a person who's otherwise quite
healthy
who did the right thing got vaccinated
doubly boosted did the right thing went
on packs of it and is doing well so i
think there's nothing wrong with what
he's doing
by trying to get work done from a
virtual standpoint you know doctor in
the meantime we're learning that the
white house is looking at holding off uh
further booster shots for those under
the age of 50 i believe under the age of
50. until uh you know we we can get to
the fall when when the
such booster shots will be able
to handle these variants and
sub-variants do you agree with that
well neil i think that's bit of a
misinterpretation of that because i've
been asked that on several interviews so
i called up
dr peter marks who was the person
responsible for that at the fda
and he assured me that no definitive
final decision has been made about that
and it is still under active
consideration but somehow a report came
out that a final decision was made about
giving people less than 50 boosters now
as opposed to waiting that's still under
active but
if the booster shots now i think the
genesis of this is if present booster
shots do not
reflect
or deal with with these variants of bi5
what have you uh that it might be wiser
to to wait a little bit when such
booster shots will be able to address
that what do you
think you know well neil it's it's a
judgment call if you have someone who's
less than 50 years old and they are in a
risk category having an underlying
disease immune compromised or even
without being immune compromised has a
disease that might lead
to a severe outcome chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease severe diabetes
i would not wait
for any other booster in the fall if
that person was due
for a booster so i think we've got to be
careful you go by the cdc guidelines but
you also have to use clinical judgment
you know doctor i had a chance this week
to talk to the novavac ceo uh debuting
a vaccine of its own i believe the
fourth now with the existing others
there are about 20 percent of the
american people who have yet to be
vaccinated at all
but i raised with the nova x ceo the
same issue i want to raise with you
right now of that 20 percent looking at
you know your close call with this um
you know you came out with flying colors
that's great uh and now hearing that the
president states got this fully
vaccinated double boasted all of that uh
as did i by the way you notice how i put
myself in in your company but
they say well well gosh if these guys
are getting it and doing all the right
things then why the heck should should i
bother what do you tell them
oh
neil i'm so glad you brought that up
because there is some misunderstanding
about that the vaccines do a very good
job of protecting you
from advancing to severe disease leading
to hospitalizations and deaths when you
have a very highly transmissible virus
like the ba-5 which we're dealing with
right now which is the overwhelming
majority
of isolates that are in this country and
circulating you may get infected
vaccines do protect you against
infections somewhat but it's so
transmissible that people are getting
infected who have been vaccinated but if
you look at the difference neil between
people who get seriously ill
hospitalized and death and compare
the unvaccinated people
with the people who are vaccinated and
boosted
the data just spring out at you as being
so obvious for the very very strong
advantage from the standpoint of severe
illness of getting vaccinated there's no
question about that so the argument of
saying that well fauci or the president
or neil cavuto got vaccinated and
boosted and they still got infected so
why should i get vaccinated
that is really a very very profound
misinterpretation
of what the real purpose of the vaccine
is is to keep you from getting seriously
ill
well i'm glad you kept me in that trio
doctor um let me step back and get your
sense of where all this fits into the
heat wave we have going on in this
country throughout much of the world now
i know there's some
trepidation ahead of the fall and cooler
weather and a likely spike in cases from
some in the medical community
but of course these are very tough
conditions for anyone whether you're
sensitive to the heat or not
in this environment do covet cases rise
they have been rising they've spiked
mightily across europe uh
they're smattering of such spikes in key
regions in china still
i'm wondering
how a heat wave
complicates that
well the only way that i would imagine
first of all we've experienced now neil
and you and i have spoken about that
that this virus spreads in the summer it
spreads in the winter it just keeps
spreading
because of the high degree of
transmissibility the only thing i could
think of as the most obvious
relationship
and connection with the heat wave is
that it drives more people indoors with
air conditioning and when you do that
and you don't have proper ventilation
you have a recirculation of the air
that could be the same sort of risk you
put yourself under as opposed to when
you're in the winter and you go indoors
because it's cold outside so anything
that would drive you in a closed indoor
space that has air conditioning or what
have you that very well could lead to
poor ventilation flow
and then again when that happens that's
always a risk for the transmission
and acquisition of a respiratory illness
very quickly doctor we have these spikes
in cases as you know and and some are
revisiting the cdc with recommendations
for people to put mass back on uh new
jersey a recommendation for all 18
counties there new york governor hochul
is uh considering the same but not going
beyond the recommendation recommendation
where do you stand on that do you
personally view
masks as a good idea in this environment
or a bad one
oh it's a very good idea neil i know
there's this sort of pushback when you
talk about mandate but put mandate aside
and look at what's good common sense
recommendation
to keep yourself safe from being
infected or from transmitting infection
the data that well-fitted masks like the
k90 kn 95 and the n95
those masks are very effective and
there's a lot of studies that show that
all right we'll watch it closely dr
fauci very good seeing you again feel
well
thank you very much neil always good to
be with you staying here dr anthony
fauci